-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight
and, now, let's get to the news.
While visiting an elementary
school in New Jersey yesterday,
President Biden stopped
to help a student
pick up the pieces
of their block tower
after it had fallen over.
Or, he tried to, but Joe Manchin
kept getting in the way.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden spoke
at a campaign rally today
for Virginia gubernatorial
candidate Terry McAuliffe.
Though, I don't know how much
that's going to help.
That's kind of like seeing an ad
for Spirit Airlines
on the side of a Kia Sorento.
[ Laughter ]
According to new guidelines
from the Biden administration,
unvaccinated Americans
will have to present
a negative COVID test
from the previous day
before entering the country,
while vaccinated Americans
can present a negative test
from three days before travel.
And people from Florida
will have to travel around
in one of these.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoo!
-This is fascinating --
Tesla CEO Elon Musk's
net worth increased
by $36 billion yesterday.
It's just a shame
that a good haircut
costs $37 billion.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoo!
-The band Coldplay
announced recently
that their 2022
stadium world tour
will be partially powered
by a dance floor
that creates electricity
when people jump up and down.
Well, I'd also bring
a generator, to be safe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I love Coldplay,
but who jumps up and down?
"They're playing
'The Scientist.'
Open up the mosh pit."
[ Laughter ]
Organizers of the 2022
Winter Olympics in Beijing
have announced that unvaccinated
athletes and coaches
will be required to quarantine
for three weeks
to participate in the Games
because, eventually,
they're going to have to be
a lot less than six feet apart.
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that long-term side effects
of the coronavirus
may include memory loss,
so, if you never got COVID,
maybe you did.
[ Laughter ]
A hiker in Colorado
was recently lost for 24 hours
after they reportedly ignored
calls on their cellphone
from rescuers because they
did not know the number.
[ Laughter ]
To be fair,
it would be devastating
to use your last bit of phone
battery, only to find out
your car's extended warranty
has expired.
[ Laughter, applause,
and cheering ]
And, finally,
New York Governor Kathy Hochul
yesterday encouraged commuters
to take precautions
over the next few days,
as part of the state
experiences severe weather.
But, just in case,
the MTA will be handing out
free floaties.
[ Laughter ]
And, you guys,
that was the monologue.